Випив пива і відразу за кермо? Краще не треба.
У Німеччині вважається адміністративним правопорушенням,
якщо рівень алкоголю в крові водія перевищує 0,5 проміле.
Якщо понад 1,1 проміле - це вже кримінал.
Навіть якщо п'яний водій їхав акуратно,
йому загрожує штраф від 500 до 3000 євро,
а також позбавлення прав на термін до 3 місяців.
Так у Німеччині проходять перевірки водіїв.
Перший етап знайомий усім: дихати в трубку.
Бувають випадки, коли водій не бажає кооперувати з поліцейськими.
У такій ситуації порушника відвозять до найближчої поліцейської дільниці.
Там лікар бере в нього кров для аналізу.
Ті, хто перебуває за кермом під дією алкоголю,
можуть втратити права надовго, якщо не назавжди.
Злісним порушникам загрожує так званий "тест для ідіотів".
Проходять його ті, кого спіймали з рівнем алкоголю в крові
понад 1,6 проміле або кого повторно впіймали з більш як 0,5 проміле.
Крім спілкування з психологом, якого водій повинен переконати,
що п'яним за кермо він більше не сяде,
потрібно здати на комп'ютері тест на реакцію,
а також пройти загальне медичне обстеження.
Скласти тест з першого разу майже неможливо.
І він, до речі, влітає в копійку!
Ну а що думають самі німці?
Чи нормально для них випити келих пива і сісти за кермо?
Коли діти були маленькі, я собі сказала, що
я ніколи не буду пити, коли вони їдуть зі мною в машині.
Це неприпустимо.
Одна пляшка - окей, але більше пити не варто.
Ні, для мене 0 проміле - найкращий варіант.
І ще один цікавий момент.
Водійських прав у Німеччині можуть позбавити і того,
кого спіймали п'яним за кермом велосипеда ...